Stopp!
Jeden Tag hören wir von Ungerechtigkeit,
Katastrophen, Morden, Skandalen oder Diktatur.
Schon 2016 wurde vom “schlimmsten Jahr aller
Zeiten” gesprochen .... bis 2017 kam.
Danach wurde 2018 als schlimmstes Jahr aller
Zeiten für den Finanzmarkt bezeichnet.
Dann kam 2019: das schlimmste Jahr für unsere
Privatsphäre.
Das alles wirft ein dunkles Licht auf dieses
kommende Jahr, 2020.
Aber, diese Headlines gab es nicht für 2012,
2005, oder 1992.
War die Welt also früher ein besserer Ort?
War früher wirklich alles besser?
Nein. Die Menschheit macht jeden Tag immense Fortschritte:
Menschenrechte, Gesundheit, Ernährung – tatsächlich
ging es uns in vielerlei Hinsicht nie so gut,
wie jetzt gerade.
Deswegen, schauen wir uns heute 6 Bereiche an, in denen
früher nicht alles besser war und ich erzähle
euch, warum ihr vielleicht euren Nachrichtenkonsum
überdenken solltet.
Herzlich Willkommen zu einem neuen Video hier auf Doktor Whatson
und abonniert gerne den Kanal,  wenn ihr kein neues Video verpassen wollt.
Beginnen wir mit einer unsere wichtigisten
und größte Errungenschaften.
Seit 1990, haben bessere Hygiene- und Ernährungsmaßnahmen
die Leben von 120 Millionen Kindern gerettet.
Noch vor 30 Jahren sind 17% aller Kinder in
Afrika vor dem 5.
Lebensjahr verstorben.
Stand 2015, konnte man diese Zahl halbieren
und die Tendenz sinkt weiterhin.
Haupttodesursache war hier: Diarrhö.
Dank Glucose-Präparaten können mit geringem
Aufwand kranke Kinder lebensnotwendige Mineralien
und Flüssigkeit bekommen.
Dank unseres enormen Fortschritts, können
Kinder aber nicht nur häufiger überleben,
sonder auch länger Kinder bleiben.
Während der Industrialisierung war es normal
für ein Kind ab dem 8.
Lebensjahr zu arbeiten.
Für ein niedriges Gehalt, unter gefährlichen
und dreckigen Bedingungen, arbeiteten Kinder
bis zu 12 Stunden am Tag ohne Pause.
Aber, seit Jahrzehnten geht der Anteil von
arbeitenden Kindern nach unten.
Das hat viele Gründe: eine Schulpflicht bis
zum 18. Lebensjahr,
härtere Gesetze und Kontrollen
– und all das hat in der Vergangenheit dazu geführt,
das Kinderarbeit eingedämmt wird.
Und es wird kontinuierlich an besseren Methoden
gearbeitet.
Stand 2020 hat die Welt noch nie so viel Akzeptanz
für gleichgeschlechtliche Ehen und Partnerschaften
gezeigt.
Und das obwohl Homosexualität in Deutschland
bis 1994 strafbar war und die Ehe für alle
erst seit 2017 legal ist.
Mittlerweile haben weltweit 26 Länder die
gleichgeschlechtliche Ehe legalisiert.
39 Länder zeigen in Umfragen eine breite
Akzeptanz von gleichgeschlechtlichen Partnerschaften.
Zusätzlich hinterfragen wir Stereotypen und
Sprache um Diskriminierung auf Basis von Geschlecht,
Hautfarbe oder Religion zu bekämpfen.
Weltweit genießen seit 1946 wesentlich mehr
Menschen Menschenrechte.
Natürlich ist es bei vielen dieser Themen
noch ein langer Weg bis Gerechtigkeit einkehrt,
trotzdem kann man, vor allem in der westlichen
Welt, einen Aufwärtstrend beobachten.
Wollt ihr euch über etwas informieren, dann
googelt ihr es, schaut auf Wikipedia, vielleicht
sogar hier auf YouTube.
Ihr habt zu jedem Zeitpunkt Zugriff auf tausende
Medien und könnt euch selbständig weiterbilden.
Das Internet bietet uns einen enormen Vorteil,
den wir im Alltag für selbstverständlich
halten.
Die Wissenschaft hat gezeigt, dass Studenten
mit Internet-Zugriff weitaus bessere Leistungen
bringen.
Andere Studien zeigten, dass uns das Internet
tatsächlich gesünder macht.
Wir haben Zugang zu Informationen und sind
in der Lage nach Lösungen und Ärzten zu
googlen.
Als ich geboren wurde, haben gerade mal 44
Millionen Menschen weltweit, Internet Zugriff gehabt.
Mittlerweile sind es 3,4 Milliarden Menschen.
Pro Stunde sind mehr als 27,000 neue Nutzer
online.
Seit Beginn dieses Videos, sind das also knapp
neue 2000 Leute, die jetzt Zugriff auf das
Internet haben.
Laut dem Oxford Institut, stehen die größten
Änderungen durch das Internet in unserer
Welt tatsächlich immer noch vor uns.
Aber auch jetzt schon macht das Internet die
Welt ein Stück besser.
Vor allem für die sexuelle Unabhängigkeit
von Frauen bietet das Internet enorme Vorteile:
es erlaubt das selbstständige informieren
über Verhütung oder Abtreibung.
Aber auch für verfolgte und unterdrückte
Menschen, wie Journalisten in China oder Russland,
bieten Internet und Darknet ein Sprachrohr
und die Möglichkeit nach Hilfe zu rufen.
Zusätzlich ermöglicht das schnelle Teilen
von Inhalten, das theoretisch kein Verbrechen
ungesehen bleibt.
Für die Protestanten in Hong Kong war es
beispielsweise möglich ,Völkerrechtsverbrechen
mit der Welt zu teilen.
Wie sehr uns das Internet nach vorne bringt, hängt auch davon ab, ob das Internet reguliert wird.
Starke Zensur des Internets, wie zum Beispiel in China verhindert freie Meinungsäußerung und Bildung.
Mangelnder Zugriff hängt auch oft mit fehlender Infrastruktur oder Armut zusammen.
Aber, allein seit gestern ist die Zahl der Menschen, die in extremer Armut leben um 192.000 gesunken.
Ich sag’s nochmal: Seit gestern leben 192.000 Menschen nicht mehr in extremer Armut.
Das könnte eigentlich jeden Tag in den Nachrichten stehen.
Sollte man die Medien dafür kritisieren, dass sie es nicht tun?
Eeh, dazu später mehr.
Unter extremer Armut lebt man nach internationalem Standard, wenn man weniger als 1,90$ pro Tag verdient.
Heute lebt das ärmste Drittel der Weltbevölkerung mit mehr als 10 Dollar am Tag.
Eine Prognose des Oxford Institutes rechnet mit 900 Millionen Menschen, die in den nächsten 10 Jahren über 10 Dollar am Tag verdienen werden.
Ein deutlicher Aufwärtstrend.
Neben Armut geht auch der Welthunger deutlich zurück:
in weiten Teilen Afrikas hat sich in den letzten 15 Jahren Hungersnot fast halbiert.
In Brasilien und China hat sich diese Zahl sogar noch weiter reduziert.
Und das alles ist nur die Spitze des Eisbergs:
die weltweiten Mordraten sinken, es wird weniger waffenfähiges Uran angereichert, mehr Kinder haben Zugang zu Bildung, und gehen länger zur Schule als noch vor 10 Jahren.
Wir arbeiten weniger,
haben mehr Freizeit als noch vor 100 Jahren.
Zusätzlich wachsen wir; wortwörtlich:
seit mehr als 200 Jahren werden Menschen immer größer.
Das ist zurückzuführen auf bessere Ernährung und Lebensstandards.
Die Lebenserwartung steigt,
dank besserer Medizin:
in Europa leben wir im Vergleich zu 1990, 6 Jahre länger!
Wir leben in einer Zeit von großer Veränderung.
Leider bleiben trotzdem viele schlechte Entwicklungen bestehen.
Es besitzen auch noch 2020 1% der Weltbevölkerung mehr Geld, als die unteren 50%.
Der Klimawandel könnte unseren Planeten unbewohnbar machen.
Und ein Rechtsruck in der westlichen Welt attackiert die Demokratie.
Depression und Angst ist auf einem Allzeithoch, genau wie die Selbstmordrate.
Das sind wichtige Themen und es wird viel darüber berichtet –
zu viel?
Immerhin sorgen viele dieser schlechten Nachrichten für eben diese Depressionen, Ängste und Selbstmorde.
Außerdem steht hinter unnötiger Dramatisierung und Clickbait die Motivation Klicks und Verkäufe zu generieren:
die Bild würde sich halt nicht sonderlich gut verkaufen, wenn drauf stehen würde: “Heute alles gut.”
Wie viele von euch auch checke Ich jeden Tag die Nachrichten.
Alles was mir dort entgeht, bekomme Ich dann durch Social Media mit.
Bei mir ist das meistens Twitter.
Dank Digitalisierung bin Ich also rund um die Uhr informiert.
Was aber, wenn dieser ständige Newsflash zur Last wird?
Können wir Medien für ein negatives Weltbild verantwortlich machen ?
Ich glaube nicht.
Schlimme Dinge passieren jeden Tag.
Und es ist gut und wichtig darüber Informiert
zu sein.
Es ist wichtig, dass wir über die Proteste
in Hong Kong, die Waldbrände in Australien
oder die Menschenrechtsverletzungen in Katar
informiert werden.
Die besten demokratischen Bürgerinnen und
Bürger sind über den Status Quo und die
Probleme in ihrem Land und der Welt, bescheid wissen.
Und so können wir dann für diese Lösungen wählen gehen.
Fakt ist letztendlich: immer mehr Menschen
auf der Welt geht es besser, und zwar gerade weil wir
über die Probleme der Menschen bescheid wissen.
Wenn wir also weiterhin als Menschheit besser
werden wollen, müssen wir über Probleme
Bescheid wissen.
Was natürlich nicht heißt, dass man die
Nachrichten nicht auch mal auslassen kann,
Joseph DeChangeman hat das in seinem neuesten
Selbstexperiment ausprobiert: “7 Tage ohne
Nachrichten”.
Wie es ihm dabei erging und welche Nachrichten
er verpasst hat, das erfahrt ihr in seinem
Video hier.
Gerne anklicken, denn es gibt auch einen Part
von mir, in dem ich erkläre, wie sich schlechte
Nachrichten auf den Körper auswirken.
Wir sehen uns also drüben.
Wie immer vielen Dank für’s Zuschauen und
bleibt neugierig.
Euer Cedric.